お前等で水ってしてるが水人は西風を取ることによって生命を維持している
成分食べ物はバレバレのは命の源ね5 f をそういうことによってこれはいいして
いる
そして成分を釣り続けることはできない我々はずいぶんをとっては政府を放出して政府
をとってはセーブを放出
そう
amaran
それが繰り返してるわけなんですなので今日は水ですもう上がった人もいるかもしれ
ませんが今回私にする実験はですねまぁ至ってシンプルですよ今から俺はできる限り水
を飲みます
あーでロンダ量の水を量ってどれぐらい水を鍋ば俺はこのに多い
照明をしたになれたっていうのを検証しようと思います
あーおれが過ぎ高上位が来て俺が小便に行って帰ってきてからした
ゼロの状態からしたんですねまあ個人差によってねいろいろあると思うんですよ隊長の
状態とか大浩に量がたまってるか関係なく多分あれは神経でこの
何鈍化でくるヴェッセン所農家らずべ仙女
農家楽メッセージによって容易というものを感じと尿意を
感じてトイレに行くっていう暴行に照明が溜まってない固まってるからどっちでも関係
ないんじゃなので多分ねー
5適当だ嫌な人だってな名舌2とか z 中に唾飲みすぎちゃってさートイレ行きたく
なったりしたらどうしようもないんですよ
うんだからね知っておくべきだと思うその自分のネットにどれだけ水をなればトイレに
行きたくなるかというのを知っておくことはまあ人生において大きな意味は果たすと僕
は思っておりますそれで次の取りに行くまちょう休憩です
[拍手]
[音楽]
秋だ
行ってきます
うわぁ it わけで今僕が暴行は多分空っぽでございます早速飲んでいこうと思い
ます
ただた
水飲み次は本当にしるんでよくないです
いきましょうマンネリとルパンと開けます非常に本当にゼロですからね
ああ
水の一気飲みって結構すごいぞよ
[音楽]
ちょっっ
4行水水水よ向こう見ずな俺
速攻で行くでいず様傷口にはネット家塩水
わー
これほんとしていっ
なんとか1 l 思いましたやばいなー水どれだけで絶えずに作る増えてるんだぜ
には2 l は入ってるね
[音楽]
薄あ
第6もう危じょんだ葉山
上から出ちゃった
[音楽]
いいします
[拍手]
def